How are all these problems classified?
Let's look on advanced search to see what the individual attibutes
of a bug report are.
Up here you can see the status of the problem.
Is it a new problem or is it a resolved problem?
If it's a resolved problem, you can look up the resolution here.
Was it fixed, or is it something that won't be fixed?
Further down you can see the version
of Mozilla that is affected by the problem
as well as the severity and the priority of the problem.
What do these fields mean?
Let's look at them in detail.
So, what are all these fields?
First there's severity, which describes the impact of the problem on the user.
The most severe problems are classified as blockers or show stoppers.
These are problems that effectively halt all further development.
Then the are critical problems, major problems, minor problems,
down to enhancement requests.
Enhancement requests are issues a user
would like to see in some future version.
They are also stored in the problem database.
Let's say that other problems are more severe at this point.
Priority defines how soon the problem will be addressed.
The problems with the highest priority will be addressed first.
Problems with lower priority will be addressed later.
The Bug ID is a unique identifier or number,
which allows you to precisely identify a single problem.
Comments are left by developers
adding additional information about the bug
or proposing fixes on how to address the bug.
Finally notification.
These are the stakeholders.
Whoever is listed here will be notified automatically
whenever a problem gets a new status.